earlier I mentioned the NSCs letter to
the attorney of John Bolton regarding
his manuscript well now I want you to
remember that the contents of volt ins
unpublished manuscript they were leaked
to the New York Times a few days ago but
according to an NSC lawyer the
manuscript appears to contain classified
perhaps even top-secret information
oh that's all joining me now is White
House counselor Kelly and Conway
Kellyanne in light of this does the
White House consider this a leak of
classified information potentially oh
people should not be able to use
classified information if that's what
happened here Laura I've not seen the
manuscript I have not seen the book I
think if Adam Schiff and the managers
are stuck quoting a book that we haven't
seen and our lawyers recording the
Constitution we win and this could be
wrapped up by this weekend I just can't
believe how people are like ants on a
sugar cube every time there's a new a
new bombshell you know what the bombs my
interview with John Bolton was it
happened on August 29th he gave an
interview to it we have no I think it's
terrific because he basically talks
about the calls that President Trump has
had with President szalinski let's
listen to it they will be meeting
President zalenski he and President
Trump have already spoken twice
President called to congratulate
President Solinsky on his election and
then on his success in the parliamentary
election they were very warm and cordial
calls we're hoping that they'll be able
to meet in Warsaw and have a few minutes
together we also have an interesting
flashback from 2010 when John Bolton was
talking about well sometimes he might
need to live for the sake of his view of
national security did you ever lie for
your country I don't think so knowingly
but I certainly am able to spin things
and a good diplomat is able to spend
things just like American politicians
you would lie in order to preserve the
truth if I had to say something I knew
was false to protect American national
security I would do it he would lie to
preserve national security well perhaps
john bolton thanks Donald Trump is a
threat to national security and that's
why he's going to spend what he spends
now I was really struck by his August
29th interview why is that important
that's a full five weeks after the
second
skee call that everybody is saying oh my
god that call John Bolton's interview
and Donald Trump's call with Vladimir at
Solinsky are very similar in this way I
don't hear the word aid demand I don't
hear John Bolton talking about Biden or
cooking up some drug deal that all comes
later after he's left the White House
and so again if people weren't sounding
the alarms at the time and the only
people who seem to have done that law
are people who disagree with the
president about Bachmann if you disagree
with the president about policy and
ukranian else I have a great idea run
for president win and then you can set
the policy I think that this entire
impeachment in the in the Senate I have
to give a lot of credit to the White
House's lawyers the president's lawyers
for this reason they look like lawyers
in a courtroom they're actually they
actually are taking it very solemnly and
I thought today was great because you
have senators asking questions to me
that's far more important than witnesses
we heard from 17 witness they were all
democratic witnesses we are Oh for 17 in
terms of being able to call witnesses
and that's why some of these senators
even those are up for reelection this
year in swing states Laura they're
saying I don't need to hear of the 18th
19th 20th witness witnesses the
Democrats blue in the house because
they're witnesses were a bunch of law
professors and each other well Alan
Dershowitz was up late tonight one of
the last people to speak and he was
talking about this phrase that they keep
throwing out nobody is above the law and
he kind of turned it on the Democrats
anything the house wants to do to
impeach is impeachable that's what's
happened today that places the House of
Representatives above the law we've
heard much about no one's above the law
the House of Representatives is not
above the law
yeah I mean they want to be able to call
the president guilty of extortion
conspiring with the Russians they were
saying all this stuff defaming the
president none of that was in the
articles of impeachment do it they think
they can do with impunity because they
have immunity because they're saying it
in the halls of Congress and the lawyers
aren't doing that the house managers are
I think it's a terrible mistake for the
Democrats have put up naked ly partisan
politicians who are preening for the
cameras as their prosecutors because
they probably offended the jury
they have a friend of the jury by doing
something else when you talk when you're
just giving your opinion conjecture
assumptions insinuation wishful thinking
you're not providing evidence you're not
providing facts some of those Democratic
senator questions today basically said
do you have any evidence of X you have
any and they repeated themselves they
think they're on a TV show they're not
under oath Kelly and a lot of folks who
are reaching out on Twitter to me
because we've been covering the real
legal aspects of this case from the
beginning so why is it that the White
House seems to have people burrowed in
as detailees from other departments or
CIA who are working perhaps right now
against the president's agenda in
foreign policy and domestic policy and
is that not a continuing Achilles heel
for this administration if they're still
in the White House today what would be
if that is true and even not just at the
White House but throughout the
administration and I think people talk
about the deep state I talk about the
shallow state it doesn't have to be that
that deep but you haven't had to be
there that long but if you're working
across purposes to the President's
agenda he appreciates when people push
back or have a dissenting view a
diversity of opinion I was actually in
the Oval Office briefing on an issue
today where that was exactly what was
happening but but working across
purposes if you're attacking the
presidency and you're attacking the
agenda and there are so many there are
so many people out there who want to
serve in this administration are you
confident they're not there there are
not people often it and I've expressed
that many times to many people I am NOT
confident about that and I am confident
about one thing that Magga world has a
point when they say there are so many of
us who would love to serve in this
administration and never got a chance
and so I think that that is that is a
question for personnel and there's a
residential personnel who are the way
and frankly for transition there were
there were people who wanted to serve in
the administration they can join us in
the second term I kept saying who are
these people and what they're kind of
working with a Jeb Bush kind of be I
mean God bless challenge but I mean we
don't understand about today look I
think this is very important the
Democrats are saying our evidence is
overwhelming I thought that when Jerry
Nadler and Zoe Lofgren went on TV after
the articles of impeachment passed but
before the Senate trial started they
made a big mistake
they probably should have not spoken
publicly because they all said well the
reason we did this was the evidence is
overwhelming we had all we need now they
want more evidence and you know what you
say is very important because I think
history will look back and say that's
terrible that Ukraine didn't get it's a
that year no actually it did it got more
and it got lose no matter what Bolton
says none of the facts that nothing has
changed chain and these buried people
probably don't realize the president's
pushback on a lot of these books I'm not
talking about this book cuz I haven't
seen it yet but a lot of these books
commis books all of you working in the
White House tonight if you're working in
the White House you're doing as a civil
servant the idea that you go out of the
White House and you dine out on having
served and getting your taxpayer-funded
paycheck and then you go out and write a
book I don't like the book writers I'm
sorry I know people everyone does it I
don't like it I think it's a coil I like
the fact that this president actually
got to go
Ukraine stuff that they can use to fight
their aggressors and Obama was basically
like the my pillow by the point has been
made a man might feel a guy but you know
what that's what so that's just gonna be
that's just gonna come out after he's
acquitted that's what it will happen
people will say why don't you crane get
a date he got it I still think we should
re-examine a lot of this foreign aid I'm
like a way to the right of Trump on that
for a long time and he's been making
people pay their fair share that's where
this all started even John Bolton
admitted in the August 29th interview
Lara there we gotta go sorry about
corruption all right Kelli I'm great to
see you and